PROFESSOR: It's a statement
about the time dependence
of the expectation values.
It's a pretty
fundamental theorem.
So here it goes.
You have d dt of the
expectation value
of Q. This is what
we want to evaluate.
We Now this would be d dt of
integral psi star of x and t,
Q psi of x and t.
And the d dt acts
on the two of them.
So it gives you integral
partial psi star dt Q
psi of x and t plus psi
star Q partial psi dt.
And this is the
integral over the x.
You've seen that kind of stuff.
And what is it?
Well, integral dx, this is
this Schrodinger equation,
d psi star dt is i
over h bar, H psi star.
From the Schrodinger equation.
Then you have the
Q psi of x and t.
On this term, you will
have a very similar thing.
Minus i over H bar this time,
psi star QH psi of x and t.
So we use the
Schrodinger equation
in the form, i d psi dt--
i H bar d psi dt--
equal H psi.
I used it twice.
So then, it's actually
convenient to multiply here
by i H bar d dt of Q. So
I multiplied by i H bar,
and I will cancel the i
and the H bar in this term,
minus them this term.
So we'll have d cube x psi star
Q H hat psi minus H hat psi
star cube psi.
OK.
Things have simplified
very nicely.
And there's just one
more thing we can do.
Look, this is the
product of Q and H.
But by hermiticity,
H in here can
be brought to the other side
to act on this wave function.
So this is actually equal to
the integral d cube dx psi star
QH hat psi minus--
the H can go to the other side--
psi star H cube psi.
But then, what do we see there?
We recognize a commutator.
This commutator is just
like we did for x and p,
and we started practicing
how to compute them.
They show up here.
And this is maybe one of the
reasons commutators are so
important in quantum mechanics.
So what do we have here?
i H bar d dt of the
expectation value of Q
is equal to the integral dx
of psi star, QH minus HQ psi.
This is all of x and t.
Well, this is nothing else
but the commutator of Q and H.
So our final result is that
iH bar d dt of the expectation
value of Q is equal to--
look.
It's the expectation
value of the commutator.
Remember, expectation
value for an operator--
the operator is the
thing here-- so this
is nothing else than the
expectation value of Q with H.
This is actually a
pretty important result.
It has all the dynamics of the
physics in the observables.
Look, the wave functions
used to change in time.
Due to their change in
time, the expectation values
of the operators change in time.
Because this integral
can't depend on time.
But here what you
have succeeded is
to represent the change in
time of the expectation value--
the change in time
of the position
that you expect you
find your particle--
in terms of the expectation
value of a commutator
with a Hamiltonian.
So if some quantity
commutes with a Hamiltonian,
its expectation value
will not change in time.
If you have a Hamiltonian,
say with a free particle,
well, the momentum
commutes with this.
Therefore the expected
value of the momentum,
you already know, since
the momentum commutes
with H. This is 0.
The expected value of this is 0.
And the expected value of
the momentum will not change,
will be conserved.
So conservation laws
in quantum mechanics
have to do with things that
commute with the Hamiltonian.
And it's an idea we're
going to develop on and on.